[موسيقى]
هذا مدى ابنا على مشاهدته في الافلام
الهنديه سنوات طويله مبالغات قصصيه بعيده
عن كل ما يمت الى المنطق بصله وافراط في
التعبير عن الشعور وحتى المستحيلات
العقليه لكن السينما الهنديه شهدت اخيرا
تحولا في سرديتها الخياليه حتى صارت بحسب
بعض المخرجين منبر لتصدير العنصريه
والاسلام فوبيا وتروج شيطانه المسلمين
وتصيمهم بالتطرف والارهاب اخر تلك الافلام
حكايه كيرلا الذي تصدر شباك التذاكر في
الهند واثارت جدلا عارما امتد صداه الى
المملكه المتحده التي يقطر بها كثير من
افراد الجاليه الهنديه ويقود حكومتها
هندوسي من اصول هنديه الفيلم يعرض قصه
فتاه هندوسيه تدعى شاليني اونيكريشان
يستجوبها ضباط الامن عن تفاصيل انضمامها
الى الدوله يصور الفيلم قاده التنظيم وهم
يحضون الشباب الهنديه على التغرير
بالفتيات الهنديات غير المسلمات باسم الحب
وذلك بهدف عزلهن عن اسرهن وادخالهن في
الدين الاسلامي ثم تجنيدهن واقناعهن
بالسفر الى مناطق سيطره التنظيم وعلى
الرغم من ان الهند تعرف بتاريخها الطويل
في الرقابه المشدده يتهم في حكايه كيرلا
بالاستفاده من الرقابه المخففه وببث
الاكاذيب واثاره الانقسامات الحاده بين
الطوائف حظي الفيلم بدعم غير محدود من حزب
بهارات جنات الحاكم الذي قدم عروضا مجانيه
بهدف تشجيع جمهور على مشاهدته
الافلام لاعراض سياسيه زاد في عهد رئيس
الوزراء مودي فقد بدات تروي قصصا قوميه عن
اعمال بطوليه نفذها جنود هندوس في اثناء
مواجهتهم لاعداء من خارج الهند وداخلها
مخرج الافلام الوثائقيه سانجاي تطرق الى
التحول في السينما الهنديه اكد ان الافلام
الجديده مؤدلجه بشده وتنشر وجهه نظر
المجموعه الحاكمه اليمينيه والقوميه
الهندوسيه